LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it'd be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
have coffee with them
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do.
And today, we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to "Coffee
with a Googler."
I'm Laurence Moroney.
And today, I'm really honored
to speak with Timothy Jordan.
And Timothy works with
ubiquitous computing
here at Google.
And it's a really
interesting turn
of phrase--
ubiquitous computing.
Could you tell us, really,
what does that mean?
What's it all about?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
it's more complex
sounding than it
actually is, right?
Ubiquitous computing is kind of
the combination of wearables,
and living room, and
Auto, internet of things.
However, I like the term
"ubiquitous computing"
because we're trying to help
developers be successful
not just on individual platforms
but across all platforms.
That is to say, maybe
implement a wearable strategy
with their app but also have
it available on the phones
so that the user can
use their app wherever
it makes sense for them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Mhm.
Now, the term "ubiquitous" seems
to suggest that the computing
platform is spreading to
whole new interesting areas
beyond the phone, beyond
the watch, and maybe Glass.
What kind of things are you
seeing compute happening?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The
different form factors.
You mentioned watch, TV,
Google Cast, Android TV.
There's also Android
Auto, and we just
recently released Beacons,
which we should talk about.
And internet of
things more generally
is just on the other
side of the horizon.
And this is Brillo
and Weave, which
we talked about at
Google I/O, which
enables embedded devices
and all kinds of things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, I'm
looking forward to my fridge
being able to compute.
[LAUGHTER]
Tell me when the milk goes sour.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
You know, I mean, that's-- those
kinds of examples have been
the conversation that the
industry has used to drive
forward like general
thought, and like protocols,
interoperability, though there
are sort of more practical
needs that users have today.
It's simple stuff
like I want to be
able to go running
without taking my phone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I'd like
to have that run tracked,
and I'd like to be able
to listen to music.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yep.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And you can do
that today with Android Wear,
right?
And that's something
that you ask a user,
and like, yes,
absolutely I want that.
And those are things that
we should first address.
The milk thing,
you know, it's hit
or miss whether
people actually care
about getting additional
information around it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I just
changed to black coffee
because my milk keeps going off.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
[CHUCKLES] I'm sorry.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
you mentioned beacons.
I keep going to bacon
because of the fridge,
but you mentioned
beacons earlier on.
Tell me like what's
the thing with beacons?
I mean, what's what makes it
so interesting and special?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's a
really good question right?
Because we've been
talking about beacons
as an industry for
years, and it's
this simple idea
of there's a thing
that has information
associated with it.
However, the
conversation seems to be
around retail or conferences
almost exclusively.
But it turns out beacons have
a vast number of applications
centered around the one idea--
beacon are about context.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right?
It's the idea that you could
make the user experience better
by making it more
efficient and yet
have the same value by
being able to short circuit
the context.
Traditionally, users have
to tell you where they're at
or what they're doing
to be able to get
the information they need.
But with beacons, you
can get that information
from the environment and then
just take the user directly
to their value.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now you've explained
a little bit in
some of your videos
about like a bus stop scenario.
Could you tell us a
bit more about that?
How does that work?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, you
can imagine the user gets
to their bus stop.
Now a bus app today
might mean that they
have to load up the app and
say OK, I'm at this bus stop.
Even if it has location,
it's like is the one
across the street or this one?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Really
sensitive location, too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right?
And they have probably
only a few routes
that they travel
per day, but the app
doesn't know that
unless they actually
tell it these are the
routes that I care about.
Well, with beacons,
the app could sense
which bus stop they're at.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right?
The signal attenuation will
give them very fine information
on the location, but then
the buses they get on
could also have beacons.
Beacons don't have
to stay in place.
And that adds
additional context.
So now when they get
to their bus stop,
there's a notification
waiting for them telling them
that that route is late, that
they can take the express.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ah cool.
Or maybe the express is
running late so it's better
to take the local.
Who knows?
Yeah.
So, OK, cool.
So now when it comes to
developing for beacons,
there must be so much diversity.
And how do we make sure
that there's a great user
experience across them all?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There's a few
things to pay attention to.
First off is the beacon format.
Now, this is what we released.
It's called Eddystone.
This is an open flexible
format that's extensible.
And it's really important
for manufacturers
to know about it
so they can build
in that compatibility
in their beacons,
which they've
already done, right?
There's a lot of hardware
beacons out there today
that have Eddystone built in.
And it's important
for app developers
to know about so that when they
acquire beacons and deploy them
that they can make
sure that they're
compatible with Eddystone.
Then there's the
Proximity Beacon API,
and this is where developers
can register their beacons
and associate data.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
beacon means this thing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And you can
even attach JSON, right?
Like it's pretty
flexible the data
that you can associate
with that beacon.
And then finally,
there's the Nearby API,
and this is what
you use in your app
to be able to cite and get
data for those beacons.
And it's a subscription thing.
The developer can
just say, hey, I'm
interested in these
kinds of beacons,
and then when one of
those beacons is nearby,
Nearby will inform the app,
giving them the data that's
associated with it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Now so there's a lot for
a developer to learn here,
and I believe you've
recently launched a course--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
--for developers
to learn about
ubiquitous computing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For all
about ubiquitous computing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
all about ubiquitous.
I like that phrase.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
This is on Udacity,
and it teaches developers
some information
about ubiquitous computing
in general, right?
The big ideas that we've
been talking about, but also
design paradigms and
technical specifics
on Android Wear, Google Cast,
Android TV, and Android Auto.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
it's a great place
if you're already
an Android developer
and you understand
building for the phone,
and you want to
get into building
for some of these other
platforms as well.
It's a great place to start.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And like developers
can just go and access the
materials, all the videos, all
that kind of thing for free.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So it's like--
it's not like it's
going to be an expensive thing.
If you've got time, go learn.
And this is a great new
frontier for developers, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Yeah, and Udacity
is a great place for
anybody around the globe
to start engaging
with this material
but also we're having an event
this fall in San Francisco.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yep,
I heard about this.
Tell us about it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So we really want
to have a conversation with
developers and with our friends
across industry,
across companies
about ubiquitous computing,
about wearables, living
room, Auto, about
internet of things, right?
Because a big
component of this is
making that service available
anywhere that it makes sense,
right?
So we really want to talk
about interoperability,
we might want to talk about
platforms and standards.
And so we're gathering that
conversation together here
in San Francisco.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool
I look forward to it.
So thank you, Timothy.
This has been great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So thanks everybody
for watching this episode
of "Coffee with a Googler,"
and I hope you
learned a little bit,
or I hope you learned a lot
about ubiquitous computing.
And Timothy, it's been
fabulous having you as a guest.
Take a look in the
link underneath.
We'll have a link to the
conference or to the summit
that Timothy had
actually mentioned,
so that you can
register for that.
And we'll also put a link down
there to the Udacity course
so you can go-- you can sign
on, and you can take a look
at learning how to do
ubiquitous computing
and develop for the
platform for yourself.
If you've any questions
for me or if you've
any questions for
Timothy, please leave them
in the comments below.
And if you want to watch
any more of the great videos
that we have on the
Google Developers channel,
please go ahead and subscribe.